neue eindrücke vom mars physik beginnt
im kopf und essen auf knopfdruck das
sind drei der fünf themen heute in den
klick zum top five news los geht's neues
teilchen nur purer zufall so gar kein
neues teilchen im jahr 2016 wir haben
darüber berichtet ging man am cern in
genf davon aus ein völlig neues und
revolutionäres teilchen den weg zu haben
das zeichen hätte eine masse von 750
liga elektronenvolt gehabt und wäre
somit mit dem standardmodell der
teilchenphysik nicht zu erklären zitat
verboten auch bei vorherigen messungen
schon vereinzelt ereignisse bei dieser
energie gesehen aber die wurden nicht
ernst genommen weil sie nicht deutlich
genug war die jetzt beim neuen lauf
haben die physiker die kollisionsenergie
im beschleuniger von acht auf 13 tera
elektronenvolt hochgeschraubt und damit
lassen sich teilchen mit großen massen
besser finden berichtete damals peter
mättig dem team vom welter physik de das
entdeckt geglaubte signal stellte sich
jetzt allerdings als purer zufall heraus
auf der teilchenphysik konferenzchefin
chicago teilte man diese enttäuschende
nachricht der öffentlichkeit mit zitat
schade mit einer entdeckung hätte eine
aufregende zeit begonnen aber wir suchen
weiter bei höheren massen und in anderen
daten vielleicht finden wir schon bald
etwas so sandra corner
sie hat die leitung der atlas gruppe am
münchner max planck institut für physik
essen auf knopfdruck experten der
columbia university school of
engineering and applied science haben
einen 3d drucker zu etwas gemacht dass
man ähnlich so aussah 2 kennt ihr 3d
drucker kann nicht nur kunststoff
skulpturen drucken sondern auch essen
verzehrfertig produzieren bisher nur
kalte dinge wie frischkäse aber bis ende
des jahres soll das verfahren sogar so
weit entwickelt werden dass die maschine
warme mahlzeiten kochen kann wie der
ganze und etwas schräge vorgang und die
präzise gestalteten mahlzeiten aussehen
da seht ihr jetzt ein video
neue erkenntnisse zu schlafstörungen
schlafstörungen sind in deutschland weit
verbreitet jeder dritte deutsche leidet
laut vielen berichten zufolge daran
entweder schlafen die betroffenen
schlecht ein wachen frühauf werden
mitten in der nacht können dann
teilweise schlecht oder gar nicht mehr
einschlafen das gefährliche daran sind
die folgen von schlafmangel im schlaf
regeneriert sich der ganze körper und
bleibt diese regeneration aus kann das
zum beispiel zur depression oder zu
hohem blutdruck führen
das sei aber noch lange nicht alles
forschern der uni klinik daran und der
uniklinik essen zufolge entsteht nicht
nur bei vereinzelten ausprägung der
störung ein erhöhtes schlaganfallrisiko
bei jeder art von schlafstörungen also
egal ob zu viel oder zu wenig schlaf
steigt das risiko einen schlaganfall zu
erliegen zitat schlechter schlaf ist ein
eigener risikofaktor und zwar sowohl zu
wenig wie auch zu viel schlaf schlaf ist
wichtig für die regeneration des gehirns
wenn er gestört ist werden plastische
prozesse im gehirn gestört ärzte sollten
schlafstörungen nicht als
psychologisches problem abtun so durch
hermann von der uniklinik essen
neue eindrücke vom mars der ma ne ganze
menge also der mars reconnaissance
orbiter der nase hat uns schon häufig
mit hochauflösenden aufnahmen der
marsoberfläche behandlung jetzt wurde
eine riesige datenbank öffentlich
zugängig gemacht diese datenbank
beinhaltet ganze 44.000 176 bilder
darunter auch rund 1000 neue bilder der
highlights kamera des mmo highlights
steht für high resolution imaging
science experiment wir haben einige
spektakuläre bilder für euch
herausgesucht daraus eine kleine diashow
zusammengestellt viel spaß
musik beginnt im kopf wie alt muss man
eigentlich sein um physikalische
eigenschaften diese alltägliche
selbstverständlichkeiten zu begreifen
beginnt das mit der weiterführenden
schule oder schon viel früher und zwar
viel viel früher anfang des jahres
konnten forscher der northwestern
university in evanston im fachmagazin
psychological science diese frage klären
wir verstehen manche physikalischen
eigenschaften schon sehr früh in unserem
leben bevor wir überhaupt aufrecht geben
können die frage wo in unserem gehirn
sich diese prozesse abspielen die konnte
jetzt auch noch geklärt werden
mit der sogenannten funktionellen
magnetresonanztomographie besser bekannt
als fmrt zeichneten forscher der john
hopkins university die gehirnaktivitäten
von probandinnen und probanden während
eines physikalischen experiment auf es
zeigte sich schnell in welcher
gehirnregionen die meiste arbeit
geleistet wird nämlich im motorischen
und pre motorischen kortex das könnte
sogar auch noch einen ganz bestimmten
grund haben zitat wir glauben dass das
der fall ist weil kinder physikalische
modelle der welt lernen während sie ihre
motorischen fähigkeiten trainieren
während sie mit objekten hand ihren
lehrern sie wie sich diese verhalten so
jason fischer von der john hopkins
university wenn euch das video gefallen
hat dann gebt dem video auch gerne einen
daumen nach oben also drauf klicken und
abonniert klicks um kostenlos dafür hier
klicken
und wenn er mehr über den war maas
erfahren wollte und das wasser das ja
dort gefunden wurde
dann klickt auf das video hier das ist
sehr spannend und was haltet ihr von
dieser idee oder von der erkenntnis dass
wir schon ganz ganz früh physik
begreifen können habt ihr das auch so
erlebt also könnt ihr euch noch daran
erinnern diskutiert es in den
kommentaren ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran